bonjour à tous en brevets dévoile un
galaxy s 10 qui pourrait sortir l'année
prochaine avec un ocz avec une encoche
en du smartphone ça va faire plaisir à
certains savoirs faire râler d'autres
mais ça on va en parler maintenant
alors rendre aux wc jamais qu'un brevet
faut tout relativiser mais en tout cas
ce qu'on va se retrouver c'est très
clairement un produit de samsung avec
une encoche en haute ou les clientes
salle tout s'était dit l'encoche non pas
la voir on va vraiment réussir à passer
outre à priori en 2019
ça ne serait pas le cas alors bon pour
l'instant comme je le disais on parle
d'un brevet donc rien n'est finalisé
rien n'est sûr mais en attendant ça sent
bon coach de vtt samsung parce que ce
qu'on voit très clairement c'est un
grand produit avec un grand écran de
bord à bord pas d'écran qui aurait cette
fois ci est vraiment quelque chose qui
va vraiment au bord complet quelque
chose de très léger qui pourrait être
super sympa avec une encoche alors
l'engagement
je sais ça fait ça partage un peu
d'acquis sont pour il y en a qui aiment
bien parce que ça permet d'éteindre
l'écran est un dock qui aime beaucoup
moins en les endettant coach de façon
elle est franchement horrible on veut
pas avoir un écran tronqué sur l'eau
alors il ya effectivement des
constructeurs comme one plus qu'ils sont
dix ans le one + 6 l'encoche l appareil
mais si on ne veut pas la voir on peut
être pas la m avec une correction
logicielle comme ça on n'a pas la subir
mais ceux qui la veulent peuvent la voir
c'est probablement la direction que
pourrait prendre en tout cas samsung
avec un écran qui ré un peu plus haut
une encoche qui serait bien présentée
par contre on sait pas forcément obligé
d'avoir l'écran jusqu'au ça ça reste à
voir parce que pour l'instant on parle
un peu dans l'hypothétique on parle
juste d'un brevet lorsqu'il faut savoir
c'est que tous les deux ans samsung sort
un smartphone flagship le modèle haut de
gamme vraiment innovant on a eu le f8
qui a vraiment changé de gueule par
rapport aux 7 et au cet âge là on a un
but en un tweet l'année dernière qui
était vraiment super beau cet écran
infiniti ce côté incurvé revue visite et
corrigé améliorer ça dépend des goûts de
chacun sur le s9 de cette année en
attendant et l'année prochaine on
devrait arriver sur le nouveau produit
avec le renouveau et le produit un peu
plus sexy qui devrait avoir les
innovations plutôt fort une question
légitime on peut se dire en 2019
est-ce qu'on va pas plutôt à voir les
écrans pliables au niveau de ce galaxy x
qui va finir un jour ou l'autre par
arriver est ce que le galaxy 10 ne
serait pas en réalité le galaxy x avec
un écran pliable a priori est ce qu'on
va sur ce brevet c'est que ça ne serait
pas le cas maintenant
ce ne serait pas ce modèle peut être un
autre modèle encore différent de la
gamme galaxy bon sa blessure
ça reste à voir on va avancer doucement
prudemment tous les jours des infos vous
en reparlerai donc n'hésitez pas à vous
inscrire pour en savoir toujours plus
mais c'est vrai qu'en 2019
on va voir arriver un tout
modèle avec un nouveau design un nouveau
look une nouvelle gueule et plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités et pour le
coup c'est vrai que l'idée de l'encoche
saab entré autre chose mais par contre
c'est pas un truc hyper innovant parce
que c'est déjà vu sur l'iphone et sur
l'iphone 10 en 2017 si samsung deux ans
après de brillants coche on aura
l'impression d'un petit train de retard
bon alors encoches pas encore ça reste
un peu à voir d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce
que vous en pensez est ce que vous
seriez pour que ça me somme nette une
encoche sur ses modèles de données 19
est ce que vous êtes fondamentalement
contre est ce que ça vous ferait aller
chez samsung
ou est-ce que ça va vous faire quitter
la marque qui m'a tout ça en bas on
commentaires qu'on puisse en discuter
ensemble ce qu'on va son brevet très
intéressant on voit effectivement un
écran un grand écran avec une encoche
mais a priori pas de bord incurvé donc
ça veut dire que l'écran infiniti en
tout cas avec le côté incurvé pourrait
disparaître ou du moins une fois de plus
comme je ne vous le dira l'écran incurvé
ce qu'on voit également c'est la
présence d'un port usb type c'est d'un
port jack quelque chose qui me qui
m'interpelle c'est qu'on voit qui a
effectivement deux boutons son côté pour
monter et baisser le volume et un bouton
de l'autre côté qui a priori sur le
bouton on off pour allumer pour éteindre
alors ce qui est un petit peu s'en
prenant ces qui épate de présence de
boutons de bétheny parce que big ben
c'est l'intelligence artificielle de
samsung
digby va se développer de plus en plus
sur le note 9 à la fin de l'année on
devrait avoir un 10/10 version 2
l'espère qui cette fois-ci traitants
français cinquantaine plutôt pas mal un
an et demi après que samsung ne saura
enfin indique ce but complètement en
français ça on peut toujours rêver mais
un douglas courval sur cette image sur
ce brevet c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
bouton bixby alors une fois de plus
comme vous le dis ce n'est qu'en brevets
ce n'est pas un produit fini donc le
champ produits finis on peut très bien
imaginer d'avoir des choses de qui
serait un petit peu différente d'un
point de vue esthétique
ils vont arriver sous tendent xbee autre
point intéressant c'est que d'eau il n'y
a pas de capteur d'empreintes digitales
pour déverrouiller votre smartphone on a
vu effectivement que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales était déplacée du
sb29 pour passer d'un côté sur les
suites à en dessous sur le s9 problème
en gratouiller l'objectif la lentille
pour pas la salir
c'était d'ailleurs arrive aussi sur le
n8 moi effectivement que les taux
d'emprunt digital et en dessous par
rapport à la caméra mais là a priori pas
de capteur d'empreintes digitales sur ce
produit une fois de plus il faut tout
mesurer parce qu'on parle vraiment
dans drevet donc d'un design et pas d'un
produit fini mais néanmoins ça met la
puce à l'oreille
est ce que pour coup ça ne sortirait pas
un espèce de faith heidi maison avec un
mclean en 3d est vraiment une
reconnaissance spatiale amélioré par
rapport à la solution qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui de facebook qui est pas mal
qui est pas non plus le plus sécurisé du
monde comme joe désignant plusieurs
vidéos en passant trouvaille des
techniques d'agent secret pour bien vous
piquer votre téléphone l'aide des photos
en phase pour piquer tous vos codes au
nom peut être paranoïaque mais c'est
vrai que fayçal dix ans en tout cas
beaucoup plus sécurisée que fashion loc
donc on pourrait imaginer d'un côté soif
side il a adapté à samsung soit d'un
autre côté directement un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée sous
l'écran c'est quelque chose qui existe
déjà
je dois fabricants et que samsung
pourrait mettre dans ces produits ce
qu'on voit également sur ce modèle c'est
qu'il n'y aurait pas de haut parleurs
stéréo band geste il nous a fait une vue
d'artiste
alors bon plusieurs créa qu'on a pu voir
passer de bendjé ce qu'ils sont vraiment
super jolie super attaque non je ne sais
pas son it bag g skin belge est ce qu'un
bail corps chez son nom désolé mais je
fais mieux avec ton nom une vue
d'artiste qui nous montrent vraiment ce
à quoi pourrait ressembler ce produit
dans le cas effectivement d'un galaxy s
10 en tout cas il déclina lui est
vraiment très intéressante parce que si
l'on comparé à l'iphone disent très
clairement et par rapport aux brevets
qui était déposée par samsung on voit
effectivement qu'une cohérence à avoir
un écran qui est presque du bord à bord
et des boks ont beaucoup plus fin par
rapport à l'iphone 10 un écran qui
pendait quasiment toute la face avant
juste une petite partie pour lancôme
stocker ce que ce soit en tout cas moi
par rapport au travail qu'a fait bendjé
ce qui est quelque chose de vraiment
beaucoup plus sexy et si on compare même
au galaxy s 9 un produit qui serait un
peu plus compact et avec une taille
d'écran pour plus optimisée on peut
imaginer un écran 6 pouces ou équivalent
avec un écran super amoled ça pourrait
être vraiment très très très joli donc
on a un peu pour tous ces enfants alors
comme je les ai faut quand même rester
prudent parce que un brevet sur les pas
d'un produit fini donc on ne sait pas à
quoi ressemblera l'année prochaine en
2019 ce samsung galaxy 10 est ce qu'il
aura une encoche est ce qu on pourrait
effectivement la moduler d'un point de
vue logiciel est ce qu'il y aura un
bouton x billet ce qu'il aura des haut
parleurs stéréo est ce qu'il aura un
lecteur d'empreintes digitales à
l'arrière est ce qu'on aura un
déverrouillage directement sur l'écran
on leur répondra faille side il n'y a
pas une fan chose qui reste en suspens
est donc abonnée vous parce que ça va
vraiment en parler c'est vraiment
défendre son super intéressant pour
essayer de comprendre un peu mbour la
direction dans laquelle va samsung avec
ce nouveau produit parce que de toute
façon en deux
19 ils vont forcément nous sortir un
produit phare est un produit qui doit
être toujours précurseur par rapport à
la concurrence
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez est
ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser est
ce que vous seriez séduit par une
encoche sur un putsch et samsung est ce
que pour vous ce serait une nouvelle
gamme qui pourra arriver effectivement
il ya la gamme galaxy avec les produits
s vitesse 9s 10
est-ce qu'on serait encore dans autre
chose mark et moi tout ça dites moi ce
que vous en pensez
est ce que vous êtes séduits par tout ça
est ce que vous pensez vraiment que les
encoches on pourra pas y couper qu'on
sera obligé à un moment ou un autre
d'abord un produit avec une en poche
en attendant ce qu'on va très bien avec
ce brevet c'est quoi qui se passe
l'encoche devient de plus en plus
incontournable merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo comme d'hab je vous
invite à mener c'est déjà y pousse à
vous abonner à marquer tous vos
commentaires suggestions question
directement bas même si j'ai pas
toujours le temps d'y répondre je les
lis je les regarde les iott et je m'en
inspire donc merci beaucoup à vous je
vous embrasse
soyez sages n'oubliez pas vous êtes les
meilleurs nous allons démontrer très
très très vite parce qu'il ya toujours
du contenu il ya plus d'actu ya plus
d'infos il ya des produits testés ya
plein de trucs en a partout donc
franchement c'est la folie à bientôt
soyez sages sérieux